the word to describe bolt is cute
incredibly incredibly cute just look at
this opening oh my god this is friggin
cute overload I just want to eat this
damn movie up look much to the movies
advantage it also is very likable it has
an enjoyable premise some enjoyable
characters some fun and action-packed
animation which I think makes up for the
fact that it's a little clunky and maybe
lagging the joke sometimes well let's
dive into the story bolt and his master
penny our super secret agents who tried
to stop evil organizations from what
else taking over the world yeah I'm not
doing it bolt has incredible powers that
make him beyond any other type of dog
that exists hell even beyond any type of
human being that exists so much so that
he doesn't exist it's all part of a TV
show a TV show that bolt is unaware is
completely fictional but bolt goes
through a crisis when he thinks that his
master penny has really been kidnapped
so he escapes out into the real world
convinced that he can find her and bring
her back to safety
he of course discovers that the real
world is quite different from the
fictional TV world and naturally he has
a hard time blending in but he comes
across a snooty cat to help him out and
a guinea pig who's just as convinced
that bolt is the real thing as Bolton's
John Travolta plays the voice of the dog
and I have to say it's ideal caster he's
very likeable very energized and totally
convinced that he's in this fictional
world the rest of the voice actors do a
good job in giving the world credibility
as well and help out this film that
let's face it is pretty much based on
just one joke but the joke works because
the character is so enjoyable and you
want to see him achieve his goal
the main problem for me though is that I
wish it did have a few more labs and
that's not to always say that they're
trying to make us laugh and the labs
don't work though it does happen
occasionally I would say just that it
doesn't try to make us laugh half the
time it just sort of shows them on their
trip and not much else which is fine I
guess I mean I do like these characters
and I like being with them I guess
because the premise is just so original
and I think so funny I always think
that may be a few more comedic moments
would be thrown in there not to mention
the classic misunderstanding which has
the character moping and doping around
yeah yeah yeah it's short at least I get
the feeling that if this film upped the
comedy a little bit more it could have
been like a really great fantastic kids
bill as it is it's decent it's good I'm
glad I saw and I may even see it a few
more times I just think with a little
retooling this could be Pixar material
or maybe even like Shrek 2 or some of
the other great DreamWorks movies then
again maybe it's not supposed to be
maybe it is just supposed to be a fun
happy little family picture and you know
what what's wrong with that a good
premise with good characters and some
good lines that's entertaining enough
for me
you